[Music]  big shake-up over there first joy behar  announced she was leaving she announced  that then it was reported that  conservative co-hosts Elisabeth  Hasselbeck was going to be fired because  of her political views  yeah but this morning Barbara Walters  announced Hasselbeck was in fact not  being fired and that she was staying  with the show and i swatched it it was  quite a television moment check it out  there is a particularly fast story that  keeps getting picked up about  Elizabeth's alleged departure the truth  is we love Elizabeth so we have not  plans for Elizabeth to leave this show  [Music]  [Applause]  what expression on hassle pay space is  so weird just sitting there like a yeah  like she's she's in the fairytale and  she's the stepsister that isn't getting  married